AND WE HAVE HUNDREDS THAT ARE
READY TO G. BUT WHY I DO THAT
WHEN WE ARE TALKING SO NICELY.
PRETTY BRET IT IS ON IN
SINGAPORE ON JUNE 12TH AND A TOP
NORTH KOREAN LETTER THAT WAS
GIVEN TO PRESIDENT TRUMP.
AND WHERE DO WOO GO FROM HERE.
AND REAL CLEAR POLITICS AND
FOUNDER AND LESLIE MARSHAL AND
MOLLY HEMMINGWAY.
SENIOR EDITOR AT THE FEDERALIST.
TOM, SIGNIFICANT?
WE TALKED OF HOW THE TERMINOLOGY
IS SAYING AND IT MIGHT BE 1 OR 2
OR MIGHT BE A NUMBER OF SUMMITS.
>> WALKING BACK EXPECTATIONS
A LITTLE BIT.
BUT IT SEEMS THAT THE PRESIDENT
BELIEVES THAT DENUCLEARIZATION
IS ON THE TABLE.
NOT SURE THAT IS WHERE THE NORTH
KOREANS ARE.
THE SUMMIT IS BACK ON TRACK AND
BY ALL ACCOUNTS GOING TO HAPPEN
IN LESS THAN TWO WEEKS AND WE
WERE TOLD THAT IT WOULD BE
IMPOSSIBLE FOR THIS TO HAPPEN
AND YET HERE WE ARE.
>> I WAS WRONG.
LAST TIME I WAS ON YOUR SHOW.
>> Bret: I REMEMBER THAT.
>> WE WERE IN LOS ANGELES AND I
SAID IT WOULD BE ON BUT NOT ON
THE 12TH.
AND THEN AGAIN IT MAY NOT STILL.
I THINK THAT KIM JONG-UN AND THE
PRESIDENT, NORTH KOREA AND THE
UNITED STATES HAVE DIFFERENT
IDEAS OF WHAT DENUCLEARIZATION
IS GOING TO MEAN.
I DON'T THINK KIM JONG-UN WILL
BUDGE ON THE TROOPS IN SOUTH
KOREA.
WE WILL NOT REMOVE THE TROOP AND
I DON'T THINK WE'LL GET THE DEAL
WE WANT AND WHY WE ARE HEARING
THE POSTURING FROM THE PRESIDENT
AND POMPEO.
IT IS GOING TO TAKE TIME AND
WE'LL HAVE MORE THAN ONE
MEANING.
I THINK THERE IS IT TWO
DIFFERENT DEFINITIONING.
>> I KNOW ABOUT SUMMIT AND WROTE
ABOUT REAGAN AND GORBACHEV.
IT SOMETIMES TAKES MORE THAN
ONE.
>> THERE WERE NO LINES OF
COMMUNICATION OPEN AND BACK
CHANNEL LINES WERE NOT OPEN.
AND HERE VISITING THE WHITE
HOUSE A TOP NORTH KOREAN
OFFICIAL A BAD GUY VISITING THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Bret: SPY CHIEF.
>> I THINK IT IS GOOD THAT
PEOPLE ARE RESETTING
EXPECTATIONS AND THE FACT THAT
PEOPLE ARE MEETING AND THAT IS
SIGNIFICANT AND REMEMBER THAT
WHEN BARK BOOKKEEPER OBAMA WOULD
BE WILLING TO SIT DOWN WITH BAD
GUYS, THOUGHT IT WAS A BAD IDEA.
THEY SAID I AM WILLING TO SIT
DOWN.
AND THIS IS SOMETIMES A GOOD
IDEA.
WORK WITH PEOPLE WHO MIGHT BE
EVIL PEOPLE, BUT TO GET THINGS
GOING AND SOMETHING GOOD ABOUT
IT.
>> Bret: PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON
CONSIDERED TO GO SIT DOWN WITH
KIM JONG-UN AND INSTEAD HAD
MADELINE ALBRIGHT,KIM JONNING-
IL.
THAT IS, THE FATHER.
AND THERE WAS ANOTHER MEETING
THAT CONCERNED THAT THE
PRESIDENT TODAY.
>> I DIDN'T LIKE THE RUSSIAN
MEETING AND I SAID WHAT IS THE
PURPOSE OF THAT.
BUT IT COULD BE A POSITIVE
MEETING.
IF IT IS A POSITIVE MEETING I
LOVE IT.
AND NEGATIVE MEETING I AM NOT
HAPPY.
>> Bret: HE CAN'T SAY HE'S NOT
TRANSPARENT.
HE DIDN'T LIKE THE RUSSIAN
MEETING BUT HE DOESN'T KNOW WHAT
IT WAS ABOUT.
>> TRUMP IS IT TRANSPARENT AND
HONEST AND TYPICALLY DIPLOMATIC
SPEAK IS MORE CAGEY AND HE'S
WILLING TO SAY.
HEY, WE MIGHT OR MIGHT NOT AND
WE'LL WAIT AND SEE AND IT IS
A GUY ON A HIGH WIRE WITHOUT
A NET WHICH IS A SPECTACLE TO
WATCH AND FRIGHTENING, WE'LL
SEE.
>> Bret: BUT THE RUSSIAN THING
UPSET SOME IN THE FOREIGN POLICY
REALM AND RUSSIA SAYING
ESSENTIALLY REMEMBER US AND WHAT
ARE YOU DOING AND STICKING THEIR
NOSE IN IT?
>> NOT ONLY THAT RUSSIA IS
STICKING THEIR NOSE IN
EVERYTHING.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE ELECTIONS.
AND WITH REGARD TO KIM JONG-UN.
MAYBE KIM JONG-UN AND THE NORTH
KOREANS DON'T HAVE THE, MAYBE WE
DON'T HAVE THE UPPER HAND WITH
THEM AS WE THINK AND WITH THAT
MEETING, THE PRESIDENT HAS TO
REMAIN ON HIS TOES MORE SO.
>> Bret: ONE LAST SOUND BITE
ABOUT THE TARIFFS AND THE
IMPLICATION OF THAT FROM THE
PRESIDENT'S POINT OF VIEW.
>> ALL OF THE COUNTRY INCLUDING
THE EUROPEAN UNION.
THEY CHARGE TARIFFS.
WE DON'T ESSENTIALLY.
THEY CHARGE FIVE TIMES WHAT WE
CHARGE FOR TARIFFS.
I BELIEVE IN THE WORD RECIP
PROICAL.
IF YOU CHARGE FIVE TIME WE'LL
CHARGE.
AND IN LIKE FREE-TRADE.
>> Bret: WHAT ARE WE DOING WITH
ALLIES.
YOU KNOW WHAT, LARRY CUDDLY SAID
IT IS IT A FAMILY SQUABBLE AND
WE'LL KEEP THE LINES OF
COMMUNICATION OPEN AND SEE WHERE
IT GOES.
>> FREE-TRADE IS IT PREFERABLE
AND OUR ALLIES HAVE HAD GOOD
TRADE ARRANGEMENTES AND THAT WAS
FOREIGN POLICYERANCY AS WE TRIED
TO HELP STRENGTHEN THEM IN THE
LONG COLD WAR, BUT THEY CHARGE
HIGHER TARIFFS THAN WE DO AND
NOT NECESSARILY IN OUR BEST
INTEREST AND NOT LIKE WE ARE
BREAKING UP A FREE-TRADE
ENVIRONMENT.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
RENEGOTIATING ARRANGEMENTES.
>> Bret: I MENTIONED THE
POLITICINGS AND YOU LOOK AT
DIFFERENT PLACES THAT ARE
AFFECTED.
IT DOESN'T LINE UP TO HELP THE
REPUBLICAN AND PRESIDENT'S PARTY
IN THE MIDTERMS ON THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE.
MORE DEMOCRATS LIKE BROWN AND
HIDECAMP AND OTHERS BENEFIT FROM
THIS?
>>Y THINK IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
IT IS IT AN ELECTION THAT IS
A BASE ELECTION.
IT IS ALL ABOUT TURNING OUT
VOTES AND SO THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT TRUMP'S VOTERS HAVE AND
A CAMPAIGN PROMISE AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT ANIMATED THE
BASE TO TURN OUT FOR HIM IN
2016.
>> Bret: EVEN IF IT KNOCKS DOWN
THE GDP. AND IF IT TAKE ITS DOWN
ONE PERCENT AND THAT'S NOT A BIG
DEAL IN THE BIG PICTURE AND TAX
CUTS THAT YOU ARE PAYING FOR BY
INCREASING GROWTH.
DOES THAT AFFECT PEOPLE?
>> IT WILL IF IT AFFECTS THEIR
POCKETBOOKS.
IF THEY ARE PAYING MORE FOR
GOODS AND SERVICES THAT THEY
WOULD NOT HAVE PAID FOR IN
OCTOBER.
IT AM HAVE A MATERIAL IMPACT.